they're calling it the big one a
four-day Gathering of thousands of
climate activists from dozens of
organizations bearing a glaring message
to the gates of parliament the climate
change is an emergency too big for
governments to ignore
rewind a few years and this is how
climate activist group Extinction
Rebellion got its message out in cities
across Europe
blocking roads and bridges its members
gluing and locking themselves to
buildings Mass arrests maximum
disruption maximum attention
and it arguably works the climate debate
is now more mainstream than it ever was
before and the group has exposed some of
the failings and inadequacies of
intergovernmental climate action but
they've also enraged public opinion
divided people's views on the group
which is why they've now decided to
abandon their trademark tactics and try
something else
we realized that some of our tactics
previously would have discouraged
certain people from being able to
exercise their Democratic right to
protest what they believe in to the
government
but there's also another reason for this
change of tack new laws allowing police
to shut down protests before they cause
major disruption and for those guilty of
serious offenses possible jail sentences
I am a civil engineer from London and
this morning I have climbed up this
cable Morgan trollland was arrested for
scaling the UK's largest Motorway bridge
last year blocking traffic for hours he
sent us this message from prison before
being sentenced to three years by a
court on Friday
practice before it burns everything we
hold there
are continued to campaign from prison by
writing articles and speaking through
the phone
I feel it's the least I can do because
there is no freedom on a dead planet
there are still other groups pushing for
more radical action as seen at the
recent World Snooker Championship
and National Gallery
and this incident involving a wax work
of King Charles and a couple of cakes
the forthcoming coronation in may
possibly two tempting a platform for
some protesters to ignore
Neeve Barker Al Jazeera London